in the veins D'Angelo Russell NBA  playoff basketball back in New York City  for the first time in four years as we  are sick freak and number three this  lady boy  [Music]  the sauce  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  your basketball is back in Brooklyn  [Music]  [Applause]  Russell sizes up the box  in control moonshine  Russell  yeah I mean shout-out to our fans you  know I think they did a great job of  keeping us in it the whole night you  know just with the energy  rustle heating up yes  so he's  please come out on fire  I think we we definitely got the looks  and warning but I mean that's what the  playoffs is about you know teams take  away what you do and you got to figure  out a way to capitalize so the NBA is  about it's never over until it's over  we're tough serious big grind you know I  think it's gonna be a grind out series  the whole time hi I enjoyed notice first  one here